tu es prête à commencer tu l'a ressenti
tout de suite dès l'instant que la tenue
dans les bras elle est comme toi
elle ne sait pas encore qui elle même
secret
[Musique]
mm
et c'est quelque chose que je suis
jaune est une fille exceptionnelle elle
a besoin de nous
c'est une trans corp je commence
sa place est auprès de sa mère locaux
[Musique]
john je vous l'avais fait
la choix
c'est moi harris et moi prenez moi tout
irait bien
[Musique]
vous voyez comme à risque
ajoutez pas
je ne vais pas que les autres femmes
exactement ce que tu cherches
le tél
je sais rien
mais ray la vie tellement
chiu
pour toi même
qui tu es vraiment
là se doutait certainement pas un con
c'est une malédiction
le terreau vision je te connais mieux
personne et tu restes avec ce garçon du
froid du mal
[Musique]
ah ça transpire
c'est là
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]